i ache on a much bigger level i can feel
this thing that is so big it's so much
bigger than the the human drama of n of
a lack of sense of beauty and lack of
love for one another is the fact that
the earth itself nature itself sees our
beauty and loves
towards us and we are deflecting that
you think it's sad not to love your
partner or spouse or child at the pure
state of beingness
it is much sadder that you cannot
receive from an entire universe that
sees you
and is sending back to you an
awe-inspired joy that you are here right
now this is definitely juliette killing
herself thinking that her lover is dead
when her lover has concocted the perfect
plan to stay asleep long enough that
there could be freedom to love we are in
our romeo and juliet moment with
universe
[Music]
welcome to the pretty intense podcast
where today we have a pretty intensely
deep conversation
with the
amazing well-known
doctor zach bush but i'm not sure he
wants to be introduced as doctor anymore
because
something that he shared early in the
episode was his
letting go of that title and of that
practice and of that office because he
realized he was feeding into a paradigm
where he was needed for you to heal but
you can teach yourself how to heal you
it's you under your power and so this
episode goes so deep and it's so
passionate we just talked about how the
body works and how reality works as
human beings everything from
the power of breath work to
sacred geometry and ceremonies to
masculine and feminine the role of aging
and whether you should love it or not
and the universe and just our
relationship with it and
and earth something that he feels so
passionate and deeply about this is one
of those episodes that you must listen
to grasping this information is the next
step
of humanity
and so if you want to be part of that
take a listen thank you for joining
i think you'll get a lot out of this if
you like please subscribe hit the like
button um let me know your thoughts how
you feel about it
until then
enjoy the episode
how are you
i'm doing extremely well i'm having a
fascinating life unfold and i am pushing
the envelopes of
my own
possibilities here this year in a big
way so it's been
extraordinarily challenging and lovely
time of growth and expansion what does
that mean expand if you like this might
be the beginning of an hour and a half
conversation but you can just go down
that avenue it feels like but
i hope so i have some very different
questions than the last time we talked
the last time we talked it was far more
like scientific so the nature of my
questions i think are going to lead to
probably some of the things that you
might start to talk about so why don't
you just go ahead and jump in with that
i'm sure what we talked about last time
included this kind of reality that we're
living in right now where we're reaching
this this pinnacle state of extraction
and
destruction of our planet and
we are doing that collectively through
a deep
misunderstanding of who we are as a
people we
have
adopted in deep
ways a philosophy that in some ways we
are separate to
our nature and god or whatever we would
consider source of life
and in that belief of separateness it
forces an immediate experience of
scarcity
and
i was realizing
in the last two years or so that i
was
a microcosm of all of that i
believed myself separate from everything
around me separate from my parents
separate from
spouse suffer from
kids separate from my
community
and there was this you know chronic
gnawing experience inside of me that was
presenting the possibility that there
was something different than what i was
experiencing there was
there was something else there and it
was compelling me to move
in a direction that i didn't know where
to move to or feel too and so i went
through a couple years of just extreme
discomfort under my skin i'm just like
oh my gosh i literally feel like i'm a
pressure cooker
what's cooking what does this dinner or
is this me
i think that might be the main course
for somebody else's dinner at this point
and
that pressure cooker experience um
pushed me in a lot of new directions of
just kind of
um
asking for
bigger answers to what what my life
would look like if i really believed i
was connected to everything and
um just led to
changes in everything
so
changes in relationship changes and
you know with my role in my kids lives
my
my changes in my sense of
i i think a shift from leadership to
more of a sense of stewardship in my
companies that i run and
and a sense of um total letting go you
have to surrender everything you think
you
want to hold on to
and so that's been in a nutshell
um my last year has been in particular
is are you willing to let go of
everything that you thought you needed
that's a lot on top of everything that
the world you're you're running that
parallel you're just sort of a fractal
of what's going on i think it's really
beneficial to explain that process
because i feel like a lot of people want
to get in touch they want to know who
they are they want to grow but they
don't really know what will happen when
you start to do that
did you
or
were you ready for that did you know
like hey you know everything's gonna get
flipped on its head and my new life is
going to cost me my old one or was this
sort of the first time in your life that
you've really like stepped into
this unknown territory of
um
change like deep change on a physical
level in a man and a reality level
yeah i think i've made a lifestyle out
of it honestly
i've been doing it for so long i don't
remember life before it really but um
you know i owe a lot to you know my my
first marriage was we were together 20
years got married pretty young had two
amazing kids and
was
that all
birthed in an environment of
uh an easy description of success
i went to church i my dad was the pastor
and
i had
met this woman and her dad was a pastor
and we both had admissions work and we
both wanted kids and
then i decided i was gonna be a doctor
and that sounds really nice too and then
i went and became a doctor and i mean
it's so easy to be like win-win-win-win
or just winning the freaking game here
and that's what i told myself
throughout my 20s throughout
probably the first half of my 30s
and yet there was this emptiness of life
that i could not calculate it was like
nothing seemed to be landing i
felt
uh intense loneliness in my life during
that time and
despite the fact of being surrounded by
thousands of patients and
yeah great kids and
family and amazing immediate family my
parents my
three siblings like yeah i
i looked great on paper i looked so good
on paper why was it not freaking
clicking like what what is
what is the essence of this that is
driving
bonkers and so
you know
my
in that 20-year relationship we started
to give each other permission to
challenge
the world views that we had grown up in
and
that uncovered deep
traumas you know in
oh man
when you hold safe space for growth it
immediately uncovers
the emotional traumas that shaped the
reality that you have been living
and
when you find those you realize
that your life is a reactive state of
trauma management rather than living
there's a big difference between those
two things and one is a slow death and
one is a constant rebirth
and i was really craving a constant
sense of rebirth and renewal in my life
and i was living
a reality of decay and
death within myself in the context of
a world that had handed us a bunch of
social norms and metrics that allow for
us to define
death as success
why do you think some people are more
like that the one you're talking i
relate to you totally i was asked some
some point in time what i've had to
forgive myself for and
it's for growing because it means that
my life does change and that includes
people
relationships work
where i live a lot of things change
but i choose me and i choose that growth
so what what do you what do you think
that is because then there are other
people where you know maybe they could
be titled this maybe asleep in some way
i don't know maybe some i think that's
kind of like a maybe a generalization
that people use but someone who's okay
with
the status quo someone that's okay with
these um childhood belief systems
staying in place their whole life like
what makes someone different i think
that the more aligned you are with the
power structures of
extraction and colonialism and
everything else that we've done the if
you the closer you align your personal
values to those the easier life is
so um
there's an anesthetization that happens
to all of us right now
when we come near when we decide to make
our metrics for
for success
very similar to those that are handed to
us and that leads to this
state of general anesthesia where we
can't feel anything therefore nothing
must be wrong
and
you can do that for quite a while before
the deep emptiness or sense of
disconnect within yourself starts to be
a an extreme source of pain in your life
and um at that moment it will express
itself in many different ways
like like
well you know as a medical doctor i see
the more the most extreme versions of it
i think that you know we have an
epidemic that began in the 1990s of the
autoimmune disease which is kind of the
most blatantly obvious version of
destroy self
you're building antibodies in your
immune system you destroy your own body
and we saw an explosion of that
condition starting in the mid-1990s and
that is certainly linked to things that
we did in our environment
glyphosate which i'm sure we talked
about the last time is chemical in our
food and water systems and rain and
everything else glyphosate destroys the
the tight junction boundaries between
the outside world and your immune system
and so now that we're eating and
drinking
roundup all the time we are
getting into this condition of leak uh
where we lose track and the outside
world leaks in we don't have a boundary
immune system reacting to everything we
can't figure out what itself
so there's that biologic reality
but we also called that chemical
glyphosate we popularized it as
something called roundup which
is kind of creepy in the sense that
he's going to normalize a population
you're going to
try to round up a group of people
and you're going to
try to corral them in a way of being
that is not real you should brand
yourself around them
and
i think that that
is
what happens in the world is we
subconsciously name things correctly i
just closed my clinic which was a really
emotional process for me because i've
had it i've my primary identity has been
as a doctor for
almost 30 years now and
or as a medical professional in some way
you know and so is
been a
a final surrender for me
congratulations
thank you
and the reason for it was because
by being called a doctor it
does something similar to
branding yourself roundup it says you
know what you all are sick
and i am here to fix you
and i realized i was part of
the problem for my patients
my patients couldn't actually completely
healed because they believed i had their
answer
i have to step out of that role to
engage with my fellow humans
in a bigger way so that they can heal
and i can be witness to their healing as
a
witness rather than as a physician so
we're now moving to the immersive
retreat model where we will bring groups
of people together to be witness to one
another's healing rather than
asking them to come into a medical
environment to receive external
inputs to find their health
total paradigm shift from
would you even call it a medical
standpoint
what would you call it
i think we're finally tapping into
something that's deeper than biology and
um
we have an eight-week program that has
developed over the last you know six or
seven years that we call dirty intrinsic
health and
it's an eight-week program that helps
lay out these eight fundamental steps
towards finding
a lifestyle that sports the fundamental
biology of human life
and it's very simple stuff and and
but once presented in the system that
allows you to
understand your own capacity for
biologic thrive state
it frees you up of of the list of
diagnoses and diseases that you had
previously been defining yourself as
but this next step is going to be
much
more
powerful because
as important it is to clean up the the
biologic environment for
a successful path towards fundamental
transformation the biology only accounts
for 0.001 percent of you and so as a
doctor trying to do something to your
body to make you healthier i'm pushing
on a lever that accounts for 0.001
percent of you the
99.99
of danica patrick is actually a
vibrational
tone
that occurs in vacuum space
that is perfectly sung by your soul
and is resonating out of this light
being that animates a biologic
possibility of a human body
and so
when people are drawn to you
is not actually for your physical form
your physical form is the direct result
of the tone that is sung below you
and the more that
we continue to tell people that it's
their physical form that people are
attracted to then they feel a burden
to that physical form
because they're afraid that that is
their identity
and that's a terrifying thing because
that physical form changes over time
and so we think we are losing our
attractiveness as humans
by living life because as i live life i
develop a lot of evidence of life got
scars on my face wrinkles on my face
sunspots
less muscle than i used to have all
kinds of evidence of change
and if i thought that humanity would
only benefit by my physical forms
presence then i would see myself failing
on a daily basis right now
but instead if i realize that i am
actually a resonance chamber that has
been defined by a light being to be
present to
change the way that humans interact with
their environment by me just being
present because i am a tone as well and
the tone that i have
if i make that the primary agent in my
life
there can be no sense of failure there
can be no sense of aging there can be no
sense because the tone is always there
and if i listen it is extremely coherent
and so
where we are stepping into is these
retreats uh that are called journey into
resonance
and
i believe this is our next step is
humanity if we're going to change our
courses we are going to have to see past
the 0.001 percent shell
and we're gonna have to look into the
beauty of the the tone
that is coming from each light being
around us
and we have to be really quiet for a
little bit we have to listen very
carefully and
the listening
muscles are underutilized we have not
been doing that for a long time
and so if we listen to each other
we will learn to
do what i think is
the closest you can come to
a physical
demonstration of a miracle
is to sit next to the four book lists
you know how to harmonize
oh um gives me goosebumps thinking about
that just
when you find those four people that
know how to bring their voices into
different tones
that when combined creates something so
vastly bigger than any of the single
tones and so not so synergistic that it
cannot be added but as a logarithmic
growth of impact of the sound that now
is emerging
there's 7.9 billion tons on the planet
that we are expressing as human right
now
the symphony that we could produce if we
were to listen to one another and come
into harmony with one another
would destroy infrastructure would
destroy
chemical matrices that have defined us
would destroy
fear itself would would dismantle
our
our belief of shame
the tone that each of us have is so
simple
and it is what provides us a sense of
self-identity that makes so much sense
i've
i remember
a long long time ago probably
20 years ago 15 20 years ago buying a
shirt that says raise your vibration i
don't i didn't even know what it meant
then like i look back and i can i look i
just saw an old interview of mine and i
talked about like visualizing an
intention like again 15 20 years ago and
i didn't even know what all this stuff
really meant but energy is something
that i'm very sensitive to very
sensitive to frequencies and energies
and whether it be a something plugged
into a wall that's buzzing or
you know just like the pure load of emfs
and wi-fi signals like these are things
that i am very sensitive to and so when
you talk about energy i really believe
and have for a long time essentially
that's what we are as energy and
so you know a lot of questions come up
with that like you know aging like why
do we age
um if we're just energy what is our what
is this
what is this information that's able to
tell us that we're having thoughts and
be aware that we are energy like what
are what is this
transcendent energy that connects us
from this life to another or to another
dimension or another planet another
universe
but so i have a lot of questions but i
think maybe still talking about these
retreats something that might be kind of
interesting and informative is just what
are the sort of
activities or pillars that you are going
to lean on in these retreats to
help people understand the pure power
within them to heal themselves
yes there's you know about a half dozen
modalities that are integrated into this
experience but um
they
they basically
go across the gamut of
the understanding of the body's capacity
to move physically move
to support the vibration of energy
within it and so uh for thousands of
years these practices have developed out
of us
and being perhaps given by direct
download or whatever but we've got tai
chi qigong yoga we have martial arts we
have you know all these techniques that
have
been used to preserve
human existence by teaching individuals
how to channel energy in their bodies
it's time for us to wake up to what the
secret was that was hidden in all these
practices that largely got co-opted by a
religious kind of
worldview or
or perspective and it's been hiding
information for us as to how to ignite
these physical bodies
by aligning it with the like the body
and when you bring those two together
you develop a massive amount of energy
in that physical body that can manifest
massive amounts of regenerative healing
and
capacity for strength
uh when i get it when anybody gets deep
into the practice of
you know
any movement technique that brings them
nearly
like body their physical bodies can do
things that don't make any rational
sense there's not enough muscle in the
body to do that activity and they don't
get ripped they don't like to look all
bulked up and muscly instead the the
mechanics of energetic the energetics of
movements become that energetic rather
than musculoskeletal
and so we have the capacity to do that
and and your qigong masters are a good
example of it when you tap tap into
their biology
when
there's a number of these masters who do
do sun gazing and they look into the
morning sun
and they train their bodies to be
absorbed light energy through the eyes
with the morning sun and they can
ultimately you know watch the sun rise
up for an hour and a half you and i we
can look at that sunrise for about you
know 30 60 seconds and then it's too
much light and it will damage our eyes
and so you have to train your body
to be able to align with that solar
energy in a non-injurious way you have
to align your light being with that
source
but they can then go for 40-50 days with
no food and have absolutely no biologic
shift towards
fasting they are not fasting they are
feasting on an energetic input that is
coming through their eyes and so we
that's been well documented this happens
and if that happens
is that a breatharian would that work
therians are kind of a different
direction but yeah so they're pulling
the energy from air instead of sun okay
okay
point is energy is infinite yeah yeah
and we have dumbed ourselves down to
believe that we have to get it from
tonight yeah and so
that's a part of this expansions we need
to realize that we interface with an
infinite energetic universe and our
bodies were designed to be able to
absorb that energy through many
different avenues
certainly uh the patterns of our aging
will change when we tap into an infinite
energy instead of 2 000 calories a day
2 000 calories a day is a miserably
small amount of energy
we are talking about kilojoules of infra
of
information from the sun that amount of
energy is just like
it's
you know it's the difference between
like the double a battery and the
nuclear power plant down the street is
this how you know ancient civilizations
does this explain
megalithic stones and things like that
is
understanding the power of this energy
and using it for sure
once you understand energy is infinite
and all energy is information then
you can communicate with anything
and so this is the solve really in the
end of our belief of separation
if the sun
is yours and you are the suns and you
belong together and you know how to
generate energy together
what can possibly challenge you
we have people starving all over this
planet
in a universe that's trying to feed them
through every source of beauty it has
because we have developed a belief that
the control
we've had the
foresight in the effort for to round up
humans
we have had the foresights to make food
a limited commodity
there's plenty of food on the planet
right now to feed 7.9 billion people no
problem this planet is so
vociferous in this desire to create food
it is just what it does
what creates the scarcity
is the belief that
those individuals are separate from god
and therefore not sovereign
and so
in our belief of separateness ourselves
then we devalue life around us and by
devaluing life around us we create
horrific scenes of suffering
by
the sequestration of resources
that have been defined as scarce
resources
and therefore create poverty we create
hunger we create all these things
and so there's an opportunity for this
massive shift to go way beyond just food
systems which i spend so much of my time
talking about and studying
but in these retreats i'm eager to start
to take small groups of people and start
to challenge that premise do we really
have to wait until we clean up clean up
all the chemical mess we've made in our
food systems do we really have to detox
our bodies slowly over time or can we
just create new bodies
our bodies appear out of vacuum space
every millionth of a second and so the
quantum state of an atom is disappearing
reappearing every millionth of a second
and so the fabric of you
has infinite possibilities of who you
are right now
the reason you look a lot like you did
two days ago is because you have a human
brain that keeps
trying to create a narrative of the past
on the few on the current moment
and so it's these beliefs of again
scarcity of life and my gosh i only have
80 years and i'm going to decay for this
whole 80 years so i better cling on to
everything around me
relationships
emotions
things
so and then suddenly you're so heavy
from all the crap you're trying to cling
on to that you can't move and you're
suffocating under the weight of
everything you're clinging on to
in the fear of being free
and so
the next thing after movement in your
life body
is
ceremony
and so once you've gone through a
morning with us in movement we go into
to
an opportunity to watch a 5 000 year old
chinese tea ceremony unfold for you
and
when you see the intricacy of what has
been developed in these techniques for
serving tea
in a sacred geometry pattern that is
rhythmed out to hold space between the
events of the tv boring
so that your mind can expand and you can
listen into your own core self we bring
you close to that capacity for listening
to your own self which is often called
intuition but it's also the
doorway into all information of the
universe you know yeah and so
ceremony is designed to hold space
and so bring your body into alignment
with your like being
move into ceremony
to hold the space for the listening to
happen and then move into a moment of of
musculoskeletal expression of that so we
do this through through static
slow movement of the body in sacred
geometry positions
and when you hold these different
geometric positions you can find the
resonance
that harmonizes with you
and so you can go through different
quadrants of the environment around you
tuning in to find what it feels like to
find resonant
frequencies around you the trees are
putting out massive amounts of resin
energy
the every
solar system in the in the universe
every galaxy in the universe is putting
out
gazillions of you know
kilojoules of energy in a very coherent
waveform and it's hitting the surface of
our planet yeah and so if you go quiet
enough and pay attention to your
intrinsic column of water within you
that is a perfect antenna you can
actually find
the sectors of the universe that
resonate with you
is that why people feel like they're
from like a certain star system or
certain like they're drawn to a certain
past life or some other uh
galactic existence
yeah it's just like when you hear when
you hear the voice of
somebody
singing the same lullaby that your
mother saying to you you suddenly feel
home you suddenly feel nurtured
and
so when i feel lonely on a daily basis
which does happen like i'll suddenly
have that little like tinge of like
um
i need a starbucks or something because
i i have this feeling man you would
cover that up
that feeling
that we are trying to cover up with all
the drugs in our environment is a sense
of we're not home
and we're lonely and nobody knows us
here and nobody understands me here and
i don't understand here
and i don't understand why people keep
misinterpreting my effort just to love
and i don't understand why people are so
confused about who i am and i have all
these preconceived notions because i
feel like i'm actually pretty authentic
and yeah i feel lonely at those moments
in the day and we try to cover it up so
tap the instagram button
look at something distract myself from
that
when we tune in there are resonance
frequencies that you're identifying out
that that are original home frequencies
and
original home doesn't necessarily mean a
billion light years away
original home means hearing your own
tune and hearing it within the context
of the other voices in the choir
and when we start to listen in and we
find that we will finally feel home here
and i guarantee none of you feel home
right now
and that's what you're yearning for you
are so yearning to feel home
at the deep core level you want to be
home
and i acknowledge that in each of you i
acknowledge that each of you are
yearning for it and it's the call for is
getting louder every day now because we
are reaching this tenor of terror on
this planet that is
not compatible with life and so we see
life disappearing under the pressure of
the chaotic tone that we currently
screen
and each of you have the opportunity to
step back into that
space of true authentic tone and listen
into those around you so that we can
create a new home here since you
mentioned ceremony i just want to touch
on it i mean plant medicine is something
that is becoming i think increasingly
more popular and
um and i think
there's some misuses for sure but i
think there's also some
deeply profound uses is that something
that you believe in or think should be
become more prevalent or going to be
part of maybe you can't even say if it's
going to be part of the retreats i don't
know but is what are your thoughts on
all that yeah it's not part of our
retreats um
so
the natural world has given us all kinds
of access points to understand and see
self and you know the most classic you
know popularized plant medicine in our
current culture is is definitely
marijuana and so
um the
the thc and cbd compounds within the
marijuana plant interact with our
neurologic system in unique fashions
and it really you know it's been
obviously in use for
since the beginning of civilization
but it got popularized you know during
you know this age of aquarius and all
this and
the popularization of it moved it from
ceremony to drug yeah and there's a fine
line between those that
is important to
be aware of in your own life
if you are using thc and cbd as a drug
it's super effective at what it does and
what it does is anesthetize
your sense of drive
and that's a relief
because if you don't feel like you're
home and you don't feel like you've
arrived you don't feel like you know
where you're going then it's a relief to
feel all that drive go away and oh you
can numb this out what a relief and we
can just be here right now
and we can enjoy the moment
and that's a relief
in ceremony with something like that i
imagine
and you have to take this with a giant
grain of salt because i've actually
never
eaten or smoked or been exposed to
sewage compounds but
what what the biology speaks of because
i do study cbd in my cancer lab all the
time but um
it certainly
is capable of connecting cells back to
their original information
and so it has a really nice effect on
cancer cells in the lab you can see
cancer cells destroy themselves
in the presence of cbd
because of a sudden awareness of their
the damage that's within
and so it certainly
shows the plant is capable of
reconnecting us to deep information
within ourselves
but at a certain level of usage or an
attitude towards it or a frequency of
use it suddenly becomes something that
numbs us out and so
the difference between a
medicine and a poison has been passed
down for thousands of years in
medical teaching and so first first week
or so of medical school you'll tend to
hear from a couple of professors the
difference between a medicine and a
poison is the dose
and that's i believe uh something that
we need to keep in mind as we popularize
plant journeys and all this is we need
to be very
aware of when we shift our usage from
our curiosity of opening our hearts and
reconnecting our bodies to a natural
source of everything
to i need to escape my current reality
because i can't stand it so i'm going to
go back into journey you know
and um
i think both are happening right now and
they always will both will always happen
and we will always use the drug of the
medicine around us and um there's
nothing wrong with that it's just
something we do
but in the course of your life you know
as an individual it's worth
constantly just doing it of processes
what am i using
the stimuli that i give myself in a day
for am i doing it
in an effort to come into a reverent
resonance with myself or am i using it
to dull the pain that i'm feeling
um and we can do that with
every stimulus coffee
to sex you know it's just
we can do it and we can use them all
pathologically we can use them all as
poisons we can use them all as
anesthetizers to our reality so that we
don't change so that we don't
move forward so that we continue the
stagnancy that we're in
so i
i celebrate the move towards plant
medicine it's an important sign of our
times that that never before we had so
many people from so many walks of life
from so many socioeconomic players
eager to experience
something like plant medicine so they
can
reconnect to something they desperately
feel need to reconnect to so
that's a good sign that we are at the
tipping point of our species and nearing
our own extinction
starting to
stretch back into our own indigenous
knowing that we all have that we are
connected to nature we and nature is
here for us not against us
it can't it's not possible the byron is
trying to kill us it's
nature if nature had wanted us to die
she would have done it long ago
especially when we started to destroy
her so severely
the grace that she has showed us over
the last few thousand years as we have
sucked the life out of her is
unmeasurable
you you can wake up tomorrow morning
just give a prayer of gratitude that
mother earth has been graceful towards
us in our
disconnected abusive behavior
uh we should have been eliminated a long
time ago if it was a universe that
believed in justice
that this universe actually believes in
growth
and it is striving for
a
possibility that a sentient race a
sentient species on a far-flung planet
in this universe
reconnects
and if it does
the whole system changes and that's why
i believe there is so much attention
back towards earth right now i believe
that
whether it's ancestors you can connect
with or your belief of angels or
aliens or whatever whatever
lexicon or narrative you need to tell
yourself that there's energy systems and
souls
you know light beings that have exited
the human experiences and are around us
or haven't entered the human experiences
and i think they are paying
great attention
they're holding space
and they are
infusing the air that we breathe with
new information that we desperately need
right now
and so rather than plant medicine in our
in our journey in our retreats we're
looking to breath work uh to trigger the
same phenomenon so you don't need a
plant to do
dmt oxytocin all the things that are
going to create your
your journey
breathwork i find is the most effective
and clean way to do journey because
there is no
difference in metabolism of breath
there's no difference of
this and
your breath is never going to make you
vomit endlessly or you know blow out
your bowels or whatever it is your
breath is going to
do what it needs to do in your body in
such a gentle way
and it will take you straight into the
opportunity to find out you don't need
an exogenous
source
of
input like a plant medicine
to bring you
directly into contact with source
that capacity is innate to your biology
you do not need anything to connect to
the god source rhythm of the universe
you know life itself
that is an innate capacity of every
single human cell
of 70 trillion cells
imbued with that capacity and so you
tuning in
i want you to understand this this just
came in so clear my gosh this is
this is the most important thing i'll
say today it feels like
when you understand that every single
cell can has the capacity to connect to
the original source of life
you will become a gravitational force
that you cannot imagine the power of you
will draw to yourself everything that
you could possibly dream of to manifest
a reality that you don't think you're
worthy of yet you will be a
gravitational force that will bring in
so much goodness to you
so much capacity for rebirth
so much capacity for forgiveness for
yourself that you can start to live in
the resonance of gratitude for the fact
that you are animated in the human body
right now the tipping point not of a
planet not of a species of the tipping
point of a universe that wants to
resonate at a better harmony we are
about to uplevel the orchestra in this
universe and all of the entities are
paying attention because our planet is
uniquely positioned in the galactic
geometry of this universe we actually
are at a chakra point uh we are a chakra
center within this universe and if we
shift this one chakra the whole system
and we
can change it for everything everything
in the universe will shift if we will
align the gravitational force of one
human being coming into perfect
coherent alignment with the the four
energies this masculine and feminine
are the words that we've put on these
energies but basically the masculine is
is an energetics of linear force and and
form and the feminine is the information
that streams through that
that geometry
and so within you is a rigid geometry
linear geometry that is
flexible in that it can
change the direction of flow through it
but its components are actually quite
rigid and so it's a beautiful reality
that we're in in that
when we start to think about masculine
and feminine we need to let go of the
biologic you know baggage on those two
words man woman you know
man it's not about that it's literally
structural
and so as we start to bring this
together
those 70 trillion
cells pulling those energies together of
the masculine form and the feminine flow
as form and flow come together within
that individual the coherence within the
single cell prevents the capacity for
any ease because it is emanating with
such true coherence to self
and ultimately that is what healing is
healing happens when you reach a
coherent state of self
and that's what i want for everybody who
would come through
something that i would build and
i had to shut a clinic
to allow that to happen because the
clinic
was a model that demonstrated that they
didn't they weren't enough every person
in there wasn't enough to heal so they
needed me they needed a whole medical
system they needed a whole thing
[ __ ] that we are so much bigger than
that we are so much bigger than that we
are so ready to blow the doors off this
thing
if you can't feel it in your body yet
then i just urge you to go sit in front
of the ocean and just
sit at the base of a mountain and just
freaking listen and then feel into your
own body feel what it feels like to
resonate and you're going to have to go
through all the emotional
overlay that's going to happen because
then when you start to resonate it's
going to shake up all of the all of the
trauma all of the doubts and
insecurities
and i just went through this in the last
12 hours again of just like being faced
with my own
human frailty
failure of expression
brokenness of like really that's that's
how i'm expressing myself really that's
how oh my god and then we have a
tendency to retract
and we're resonating higher so we're
exposing new things and everything wants
us to retract and be afraid of our own
power
and the message that came through this
morning is so clear is go bigger go
bigger
go bigger than that because we can get
there go bigger than the fear of hurting
each other go bigger because it's okay
to hurt each other if it's out of an
effort to get to our own resonant state
of truth
we will have enough grace and
forgiveness for each other to work
through the relational challenges that
come
you are going to create a lot of
disruption in your life if you do any of
the things we've been talking about for
the last hour it is going to be
extremely disruptive and so that's my
disclaimer on all of this
you are treading on holy ground when you
step into these spaces and if you start
to go down this path it will be
extremely destructive to your current
way of life
and thank god for that thank god that
you have the possibility of blowing up
the matrix you can just
push
all of you can push right now
and i don't think it's going to take
more than two of us
to change everything
it really just come into perfect
harmonic alignment with those mask and
feminine the course of miracle says if
one pair
will come into complete coherence it
will change the consciousness of the
whole planet
and scriptures all over the place say
this where two or more are gathered i am
where two or more are gathered i am
i am
the most beautiful thing you will ever
see can you get to that point where you
can
sit there and close your eyes and say i
am
the most beautiful thing the universe
will ever see it's going to take some
ceremony it's going to take some
dismantling
belief systems
have you been able to say that
i said it for the first time
at the end of january this year and um
it was really hard fought to get there
i had to dismantle a lot of my life to
get there and
the human mind
is so conditioned into a split state
with the ego
shield that
it's
not a one-step
event
uh it creates you have to create a
lifestyle that allows for the the
possibility of being able to say that
in a continuous soundtrack of your life
rather than
a one-time connection to that reality
the one-time connection
happens in a million different ways and
uh for humanity
but a world that perpetuates that day in
and day out has not been seen yet
and so that's our challenge uh to all of
us
but the exciting thing is you don't have
to imagine what that would look like it
will simply be manifest out of
the space between everything we've
created that new reality is going to
emerge
and in just recent weeks i had this deep
feeling that we have it's already
finished that already happened
and now our neurosensory complex that we
call human consciousness is catching up
to see it
but i believe it has happened
i believe that on this
continuum of life and light beings
we completed something
in the recent weeks that's extremely
important
and we've done it in the midst of school
shootings we've done it in the midst of
new efforts toward war we've done it in
the midst of one of the worst famines in
in history in africa we've done in the
midst of
cataclysmic damage to the planet uh that
we continue to met out
and so
that's the grace of the universe is
the harmonics of light beings
cannot be dismayed
by the behavior of a little bit of
biology how are we the same as the
planet because when we know how to take
care of ourself we take care of the
planet we know how to take care of the
planet we can maybe know how to take
care of ourselves so one of the biggest
aches i feel in myself is
that most humans are walking around not
knowing or not being able to hear how
much they are left
and it sends such deep ache into my body
when i become present with that
knowingness
there are 7.9 billion people walking
around in an incomplete knowledge of
and perhaps not even the inkling of
experience of how much they are loved
and love is um not a thing
love is an experience that happens when
you see beauty
and when you see the beauty and nature
around you you are experiencing love at
its purest form
love is a frequency of resonance that
occurs when
your
being witnesses the beauty of another
being
and the most exquisite being that we all
share is this planet
and so our connection to the divine is
the nation we live within
and
if you will go out to watch a sunset
wherever you are
i promise it's the same sunset i'm
watching tonight wherever i am
we are sharing the beauty of this planet
all the time if we will stop and listen
and the reason i feel such egg is not
just because we are walking around not
loving each other because we can't see
the beauty in ourselves therefore we
cannot see the beauty in the other human
next to us
i take on a much bigger level for some
reason i i can feel this thing
that is so big
for some reason
it's so much bigger than the human drama
of a lack of
sense of beauty and lack of love for one
another
is the fact that the earth itself
nature itself sees our beauty
sees our beauty
and loves
towards us
and we are deflecting that
you think it's sad not to love your
partner or spouse or child at the pure
state of beingness
it is much sadder that you cannot
receive from an entire universe that
sees you and is sending back to you an
awe-inspired joy that you are here right
now
that you are here right now
what a what a tragedy
this is definitely juliet
killing herself thinking that her lover
is dead
when her lover has concocted the perfect
plan to stay asleep long enough
that there could be freedom to love
we are in our romeo and juliet moment
with the universe
are we going to kill ourselves in our in
our sense of hopelessness
because we thought that we what we saw
was real
or are we going to realize there's a
deeper reality that love cannot be
conquered and therefore it is not dead
and therefore we should stay alive long
enough to feel it
and if she had just waited a few more
minutes
if she had just waited a few more
minutes we wouldn't have that story to
tell
and so i invite all of us
to stay alive a few more minutes
together let's encourage each other to
stay alive a few more minutes
and wait for this story to get to us
that has already completed itself which
we are loved we are seen we are home and
this is our home and we will make it
home when we resonate together when we
harmonize we will find the symphony of
the new humanity and we will express
something much different than we have
before
[Music]
beautiful and
i'm sorry for that ache and pain i think
that we all have our own
little
ways in the world where we can feel
something so deeply and
you know you express yours and i think i
can think of mine and
you know i think probably people
listening can feel theirs too and where
it is that they feel that vein of
reality
so deep into their bones and it's just
it's visceral
so thank you for
sharing that you had talked about it a
little bit earlier about the masculine
and feminine what are those roles what
are they in any way separate like they
have roles
and how does the mind play into that
because the mind feels very masculine to
me and
perhaps there's been things that happen
on this planet that are driven by that
mind by the by the egoic mind
um
so what is the role of the masculine and
feminine
and how do you
how do they come together in
coherence and balance
so that we can unite so that we can
balance
and reach homeostasis
the masculine is a goal-oriented
structure that
has finite boundaries to it uh that
can be stacked in infinite directions
and so you have all these finite events
that that can fill the infinite space in
the masculine form
uh and that's very
critical to the fabric of the universe
it is the fabric of the universe is this
form
of infinite
grid if you will and so if you picture a
bunch of cubes you know stacked up and
the cubes are
simply spaced defined by
thin little rods on each you know edge
of the cube
so you have space defined by this cubic
grid
that could maybe give you a visual of
what the masculine
energy
form looks like in the universe at the
atomic level at the subatomic level of
the quantum realm of reality we have
this grid
the grid is actually
mobile because
each corner of the cube is
not
rigid and so the bars of the cube can
actually flip through
to connect to a diagonal across that
cube
and so while it looks very boring and
structurally cubic and linear
in its capacity create diagonal
relationships across its finite form it
creates infinite possibilities of flow
through that math matrix
the feminine is the energy the infinite
energy of the universe that will flow
through that matrix
so at the sub-atomic particle level you
have this phenomenon of rigid rules of
engagement of
atomic structures
you know
down at that boson you know god particle
level
there are strict rules of engagement
there's this rigid form
that the moment you look at it
dissolves disappears and becomes
something else the moment you witness
anything anything witnesses the other
thing it
it it changes direction it changes form
and so that
transmutative power is the feminine's
capacity to flow through that that rigid
form of the masculine
and so that
you've got basically an infinite game
being played through a finite
structure
the infinite is the feminine finite is
the masculine
and we all hold both of those
right capacities
what we've done as a society is we've
built a billion finite things and forgot
that we were playing an infinite game
and so that's why we created waste
streams
um i just uh we're just launching my
energy company called resource dynamics
we i've been working for seven years to
build a 40-foot mitochondria that breaks
down plastics tires farm waste into
biodiesel that machine is showing us
something about
our capacity to create an infinite game
out of out of natural resources rather
than these finite games of extracting
oil turn it into plastic dump it in the
ocean
and so
we played a finite game that's extracted
all of life out of earth if we had
understood that earth was
a feminine masculine archetype that is
asking us to build finite things out of
infinite resources and return those into
the cycle of life then we would have
we would have no waste on the planet and
so our little company
which is growing
in attention quickly now because its
time is so poignant because we're
obviously running out of the resources
we we so extracted into these waste
streams
and if you look at like all of the
technologies there's like sustainability
and all this like it's actually kind of
doing pretty good in fact that like the
amount of electricity that takes or the
amount of resources it takes per capita
is actually decreasing right now so
we're becoming more efficient in the
ways in which per individual of course
we have way more individuals than we
ever had so that's a bit of an issue but
but pretty capital there except for
waste
every individual is generating more
waste than any individual in human
history has ever done
and so we are at this extractive level
where we're pulling all this stuff out
and turning it into waste
and so that's what our company is trying
to step in just to show everybody is
like there's no such thing as waste in
the universe there is not one iota of
waste it is all energy it's all infinite
it is all in an infinite game and so
this is where we need to start to
redesign energy systems education
systems for god's sakes the fact that we
test kids out of third grade and say now
you're in fourth grade like what the
heck are we thinking like
it just doesn't even none of it makes
sense there's no feminine flow through
that concept of education right now and
so we've turned it all into this finite
billion finite games that are
disconnected and irrelevant to one
another and keep stepping through your
hoops and checking your finite boxes of
life did that graduated got married got
the job got the promotion got the car
got the house got the kids got the dog
got the freaking horse whatever it is
and and you played a million finite
games you can't find the relevance of
any of it because you forgot that you're
in an infinite stream of information
that is called life and so whether we're
talking about energy sector and natural
resources and our capacity to reconnect
that or we're talking about your own
spiritual experience there's this dance
between the important rigidity of the
the
the stability as a better word than
rigidity then the stability of the
masculine energetic function and form
within you
is there and i love the the question
that was posed to me which is what is
the role
of the masculine feminine i love that
word because it's it supposes and is
correct in supposing that they're
neither is even relevant unless they are
in a relationship
there's no role for you if you're just
alone you're if you're alone
there's no hierarchy either there's a
role to create sort of this
braiding of energy to
become you know juliet is just juliet
until you put her in the context of the
entire cast of the play
and now she has a role
yeah
exactly and so you have a role once you
step into
the infinite game of humanity right now
you've defined yourself as a finite
element within humanity and therefore
you are lonely and disconnected you feel
unseen unheard unloved
plug yourself back into the infinite
nature of life itself and find your role
is to be in harmony with those around
you but to get into harmony you've got
to listen to the tones around you
so is it a matter of trying to
create harmony with the masculine and
feminine within the self only or is
there
or is it an and
where it's an and create harmony perhaps
with a masculine and feminine energy
with two people as well
and is is it an ongoing sort of fractal
nature of masculine and feminine
polarities that create balance or is
this just limited to
or only necessary to do it within the
self you just ask the most important
question
for humanity right now
in the course of miracles definitely has
been teaching this for 30 years this is
not my idea or reality but i just
started reading that by the way i'm with
like four other girls doing a course of
miracles with them and we're like a
couple weeks in so i'm so glad you've
referred to it a couple times okay keep
going sorry
your current paradigm is completely
screwed
i know it starts off with saying
basically like nothing is real nothing
matters and you're like okay so
but i you didn't call oh but that
doesn't matter nothing matters okay
anyway i just thought i'd share that
because i just think it's like such a
synchronicity how many times you've
referred to now the course in miracles
um but okay getting back to the
masculine and feminine so the course
miracles um
shows us that that the way in which we
have tried to solve for this necessity
of balance between the mass and feminine
energies is through
relationship with two people
or two things
and so they call it they call this
special relationship and so the special
relationship is where two split minds
that are incomplete and therefore
protected by ego
get together to try to complete
a whole mind and so you have two split
minds that come together and say oh do
you want to be my person because i'm not
complete you're definitely not complete
i can see all your problems and i think
i could fit myself in and and solve for
your incompleteness
the moment we do that we just became
uh
the narcissistic version of god right
and like oh i'm gonna fix you you fix me
i'll fix you
we don't we don't thank goodness we
found each other because certainly we we
couldn't have done it ourselves
otherwise so we created all these
special relationships and um if you take
a look at the list of traits of a
special relationship
it's a horrific list of agreements that
you have to come to
and they include the first line is you
now have to agree that there's two
dueling egos with different agendas that
will battle it out
sounds fun excellent sign up for that
for sure
you have to believe in death
and interest and we even put language to
that until death do us part
and so
so we have to believe in the finite when
you say you believe in death if you're
going into special relationship then you
have to believe in death
because if you really believe the
infinite then it's impossible that this
is your person because you've always
been here long before this person showed
up and you're gonna be here long after
that person and so you have to believe
that your entire finite existence is all
there is to it and there is no infinite
nature of you and you just made an
agreement to believe in that and you're
gonna put all your energy into the
finite game together
and so we did that with our cars we did
that with our houses we did that with
our education and our jobs
we created special relationships all
over the place in an effort to complete
ourselves
and so what you'll find is you keep
going through that course in miracles
we're bringing being called into a
different reality where we complete the
mass and feminine within
each individual we solve for the split
mind and we we resolve the need for the
ego
by completing the mass and feminine
within ourselves and we find completion
there and then
we will go into a form of relationship
that's never seen been seen before
and that will be beautiful
i got this i got that download i've
never shared this before but it was in
an ayahuasca ceremony and
the information was an ego death to this
idea of a perfect relationship of like
two people coming together in perfect
symbiotic nature it's joyful it's
balanced it's perfect
and the message was
you have to create that with yourself
you don't get that with somebody else
you have to do it with yourself that
perfect relationship is with yourself
and then the other then the relationship
is actually not different than what you
want it's still there it's just that it
starts with the one with yourself
and then the relationship
is there
and
it's been amazing how long it's taken to
integrate all of this and bring the
puzzle pieces in together
on what that really means but when you
shared that i just felt compelled like i
had to share that you saw it i saw it
and it was a total i cried and cried and
cried and cried and cried
probably four or five waves of crying
and then finally i accepted it i'm not
gonna say that i like all of a sudden
knew how to do it but i i i accepted the
information
um so we can create harmony by doing it
with our self and then the nature of our
reality completely shifts and if you
read the list of traits of an of what's
called the holy relationship in there
but i i i
the word holy can be loaded for people
and so um i i've been using the word
vertical relationship once you find that
vertical where you have completed that
masculine feminine and you no longer are
horizontally trying to complete yourself
to all these other split phenomena
when you go vertical and you complete
that
the list of
of traits of the relationships that will
then result when two people that are
complete and themselves come together
and common mission common vision for
creating co-creation the list is
beautiful
instead of
instead of the dissonance that is baked
into the special relationship that we've
all known we will find
ultimately at the core of it right in
the center of the list is the word
immortality
we will come to be
the infinite game in relationship
we will come to see that every human
engagement
is likely
a
a harmonic
of many
contacts before with that person
we're going to realize that those that
we are drawn to tune to those that we
are called into harmony with
are the members of the choir we've been
singing with a long time
and we're going to stop seeing and
defining
a relationship as
a few dates or
three-year relationship
we will start to see it as eons of two
souls coming together on purpose to
align for a resonance frequency to
change a planet or change a nature and
we'll start to be able to see the impact
within each of us
danica you and i when we first met it
was so obvious that there was a
knowingness that ran
illogically
i'd never met you i'd never had seen you
a few times through press and things
like that and then walked into your home
there in
in california on the coast there and
walked in and
you took me down to this little grassy
patch that was down the hill and it was
such a
mythical like little path that went down
to this strange little like
patch of
grass that was among these things
and i remember having my shoes off and
putting my feet down there and the
crashing of the oceans right below us
there and it was just epically beautiful
but there was such a
it was such a unique little spot right
there and on that grassy spot and you
sat down there and then you were
probably 10 feet away from me or
something and i
there was a familiarity about seeing you
in the context of nature that i was like
holy [ __ ] that's really familiar
yeah i didn't say anything because
that's socially awkward and everything
else you don't say these things when
they come up necessarily but there was
there there's an awareness of oh my gosh
that there's a memory right there
that is not from my lifetime right here
i think my soul knows that thing
i i think that i recognize that harmony
right there that is in that space
and i think when we get to a point of
social understanding between each other
when we can simply acknowledge those
moments without them feeling like
something weird or
you know come on or whatever it is like
we're going to start to remember oh my
god we've been singing together
for eons on many different planets
perhaps like we have just we are light
beings that are here to sing together
and we need to lose the frailty of our
human insecurities and human beliefs and
and the finite definition of who we are
and start to blow it out and let the
infinite reveal itself in the finite
structure that we are let the infinite
reveal itself to realize oh my god this
is so stupid it's a cosmic joke
that we think any human thought is real
any human creation is relevant it is so
dwarfed by the reality of 7.9 billion
like beings that are hanging out
together on purpose of mistaken geometry
create a perfect resonance field to
complete the center chakra of the entire
universe
so don't worry about what you're doing
this evening
yeah right exactly like let's not look
at those little things and worry too
much thank you for sharing that i have
to share a story even just from right
now just to
continue to um
help people understand maybe another
aspect of relevance even just the things
that i wanted to talk to you about today
you just started checking them off on
your own like you knew what i was gonna
ask or like you could feel the frequency
of whatever information it was that i
was curious about like from a quantum
perspective
our energies
are aligned and i i mean i was as you've
been talking i'm like yep there it is i
literally like i was going to ask you
about the masculine feminine sure enough
there it was and many other things so i
think that it's really i think it's good
to explain those things to people so
thank you for sharing that connection
that first time i felt that too it felt
so it did feel familiar you it was so
easy
um and um
and yeah i'm so glad that we're doing
this again i wish we were in person
um
so what i'm curious then
what this
because there is something finite about
us our body right like our human body do
is that a finite thing every millionth
of a second
every millionth of a second do you
believe then that we should or could
live forever in this human body is that
some is that a is that a is that
something that you believe in that
sounds pretty miserable to me i don't
want to live forever in anything so i
want to say it so i think that's why we
don't we don't
we don't cling to these bodies because
it's the finite game we're in an
infinite game we have roles all over the
place right right right
what is humanness then what is humanness
is humanness
um having a mind having an ego is
humanness aging
like what is humanness
humanness is the opportunity to touch
the finite
because we're always infinite beings but
it's boring to just be infinite you want
to be finite and infinite
human one of the many opportunities to
be finite
and so it's not that finite is bad it's
just finite if it becomes your reality
it becomes terrifyingly small
and destructive and lonely
we became human so that we could
experience the finite
i don't think that entities that are
outside of a physical body can sit can
have the experience of of watching
steam rise off the surface of a cup of
tea in the morning in the sunlight
because
you have to have a physical body that is
defined by finite
realities
to experience time and without time
you don't get to see the steam rising
off the cup of tea
and so your physical finite
humanness
allows you
to experience beauty
through the eyes of the finite
neurologic experience of being human
and so tell the angels around you how
beautiful the sunset is
they can feel the sunset but they can't
see
the sunset
time's integral to our experience
time is a result of our finite existence
and so the
phenomenon of aging is a celebration
of a million finite experiences that
stack up
and
this week i'm i'm
losing my adopted grandmother that came
into my life just a couple weeks after
my my favorite
relative and grandmother passed away
and i've been with this woman for eight
years and uh she is a matriarch among
matriarchs this woman is a
extremely powerful soul and
carries so much wisdom in her
and she's passing right now and she's in
transition and i sat with her all night
long a couple nights ago and
if you just close your eyes for a moment
and think about
the hand that you would hold at your
grandmother's bedside at the end of her
life
and look at her face and look at all the
wrinkles around her eyes
listen to
the
the breath as it comes kind of ragged
now too weak to pull itself in
you have to hold your head really close
to their mouth to hear them speak
because it's just a whisper now
do you feel like that person is failing
right then
would you get frustrated them for not
bucking up and keeping going
it is one of the most beautiful things
you will ever see
is somebody letting go of the physical
body at the end of a life
thoroughly lived
and the record of all those finite
moments is the beauty that we see in the
face of an elder
and so when you start to realize the
infinite game within the million finite
moments then you're going to realize
that the wrinkles that are appearing on
your face in the mirror in the
morning is the emergence of the wise
grandmother that you're about to become
you might shift an entire existence with
that line right there
we want to be the wise elders
we need to stop eschewing
the appearance of time on our faces
because it's the journey we signed up
for
so that we could see the beauty of the
universe
through finite perspective and then
share that with
all of the light beings that are around
us and that are surrounding our
experience remind your ancestors that
are with you in spirit remind them of
how beautiful the sun is because they
can't see it anymore
they can feel it but they want to see it
through you so celebrate that sun set
not just for yourself
but for all of
life within the universe for all
vibration
sing your your gratitude for that sunset
so if death is not an endpoint and what
is it what happens what comes next it's
a
it is such a
moment it's a millionth of a second
ripple
in the infinite journey
it's a millionth of a second to let go
of that body and the moment you do let
go of the body it's so visible i was a
hospice doctor four years and we were
admitting 80 patients a week to our
little service and after the whole
agency 240 patients a week and so you
start to multiply that out times 360
days times four years you see a lot of
transitions
and when you see that many transitions
you realize not a single one of them was
an endpoint and that each of them was a
letting go because you get to watch the
body be let go up uh the animation of
the body when the soul likes go is so
obvious like you don't want to go check
the pulse to say i wonder if she just
died
like it is so instantaneously obvious
you can feel it in every cell of your
body that life just went out of that
body
that life cannot be destroyed all of
that energy not a single iota of that
energetic field can be destroyed that
being simply completely let go of this
form and became something
instantaneously on the other side of
that form
just in the thousandth of a second or
whatever of a second
billionth of a second that we're
appearing here yes
and so you are immediately
the other thing
and is there's no transition there's no
like waiting for your next karmic
journey it's
you are in it and you're you're
traveling
and you're a light being
and you are now moving through space and
time
it is not there's no process to it it's
instantaneous
okay what's the
what's the next version or
vision
of what
a lot of
people in the spiritual community
and maybe even more than that now would
call
new earth
it's coherent and so
nature is coherent and um
the new earth is sitting right in front
of us it's always actually been here the
new earth is the capacity to perceive it
it's our capacity to perceive the
reality that we're in that is going to
reveal the quote-unquote new earth it
doesn't come out of it it doesn't even
it's freaking right in front of us
it's here it always has been here but in
our belief of separateness from the
source and that bread a behavior of
scarcity
uh we we failed to see the beauty that
we live within and so
um it will instantaneously appear in
front of us and it will welcome us so
i think you're going to probably bring a
lot of people into that new paradigm a
new reality
and
new balance within themselves with all
of the work that you do you do so much
work and thank you for your bravery to
step into
what's calling you and allow a
dismantling and you know i love the
analogy or like the visual because i'm a
visual person example of
um
cymatics when you see
um sound creating a shape a pattern
uh and then as the frequency rises the
the sound becomes more
it goes into a new higher frequency
there's a dismantling a complete mess
and then a reestablishing of
a new more complex
pattern
and
thank you for allowing your world to
dismantle so that you can help create
this new pattern and and lead us into
that and be
a good steward of the information that
comes through you
and
your willingness to
to stand in it
thank you very much i'm very willing to
keep
walking my walk into that reality but
each of you are gonna have to walk your
walk i can't i can't lead you there and
i can't take you there and it's gonna be
an individual journey and
um so that's that's me having to
verbalize that because my tendencies
over the last 50 years has been to
russian and help people on the journey
and that that
has been a discredit to your sovereignty
and your capacity to find your intrinsic
journey back to source and
so enjoy the journey i'll celebrate
alongside of you as we as we all walk
into that that uh opening of our eyes to
see that new earth
all right thank you take care
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today i hope you
enjoyed it if you like what you heard
today and you want to hear more please
click on the subscribe button